alright folks welcome to odd-man-out I
know this is an awkward new setup in the
age of coronavirus if everybody feels
ready give me a thumbs up what makes a
man a man aside from the obvious you son
of a [ __ ] is it the way they think or
have a feel or what they do
what is masculinity and a lot of young
men feel more conflicted in today's
society than ever this question is on a
lot of people's minds and the answer
always seems to be changing so we
decided to make an episode about this
question we brought together six guys
and one secret girl with cameras and
mics off words only can they find the
odd woman out
[Music]
all right strategy do you target the
guys or do you target the one girl and
try to lead her out my strategy going
into this real close attention to the
chat hopefully I can pick out a little
tweet so I bro wouldn't say I'm gonna be
asking very life based questions about
being raised as a boy I'm a straight
white guy I work out I watch football
what else did I say anything that I
could say is something somebody
researching would say I'm gonna find
somebody I trust I guess I'm just gonna
look out for the more stereotypically
male and female traits to feel like the
mole might actually just like exploit a
lot of those well I want to stay as true
to myself as I can but being how I'm a
little more feminine if there's an
opportunity for me to not mention
something that's feminine I'm gonna take
the opportunity I guess we'll see I'm
not confident at all you Jubilee editors
you're gonna have fun with this when I
can tell you that I don't want to be the
one who's headstrong I don't want to be
the one who's not doing enough I just
want to be standard average laying low
keeping it cool not overdramatic not
anything like that just stay low
all right so right off the bat
everyone's just like any introductions
like what's their name door to Irvine
okay bow everybody's ages in we're about
we're all about the same area lines and
high school students I work in carpentry
let's say that because that's actually
I'm very suspicious of the others
eighteen year old here they said boys
not men involved working a carpentry
nation you need major with pants eyes
what come on that's not fair
hey Tristan I see you 30 32 I feel like
I want to ask I do not respond okay so
we're talking pan sizes that are nowhere
oh my god I'm so embarrassed
Chandler and Ryan are on my radar
Chandler and ride
huge fan of video games I loved the Last
of Us and until dawn and all that stuff
see Brian you know my wife I decide to
start crapping out on me at the worst
time okay I really don't know what to
say but I don't go Spurs go until
dinosaur I'm rolling here god we got it
we got a vet out of somebody
this is not how I chat in real life oh
my god all right send me the name of the
person you suspect is the mole the
person that has me looking at them
sideways in this round is Ryan you know
I'm really suspecting Chandler Michelle
Norris answers were a bit vague Tristan
just seems to be acting a little strange
to me I had a really hard time keeping
up with the other guys because my
internet connections starting for a
little spotty I went with Chandler he is
not talking much at all I'm voting Ted
either Chandler or Ryne they don't know
their own pant size so Ryan you know
hitting them with the XD this whole face
frankly I don't I don't buy it
I've either found the perfect partner in
Bryan or I've made a huge mistake
I don't think it's Bryan Bryan's
mentioning a lot of I think poor guy
things
so I kind of held back I guess and I
think that get sense that that's kind of
that's probably why I gotta put it out
that happens about that pause game now
mate so what's something you feel that's
inconvenient bout being a guy I feel
like that's the typical question anyone
can ask
cuz that way because a lot of things you
will see early show is that seriously
okay let's be on sitting on the ball he
was always being seen that guy this
chandler channel it's interesting it's a
little political tries to do socially
aware but in the street white dude I
think I'm never valid allied to any
group being tough I feel like
[Music]
we can't wear makeup but build Stanwell
peeve I hate first place we go always
that was probably my death sentence I
just said you couldn't make it
we can't wear makeup that's true we
cannot wear makeup in any confidence
confidence who cares what the others
think my dude piss over here B Chris
over here is a tad masculinity is
company yes sir what shampoo I thought
about that how many girlfriends or
boyfriends I don't judge it you guys
okay so I'm asking how many how many
girlfriends or boyfriends three-in-one
swab let's go all right Chandler hang on
still on the fence
that's all I'm gonna say I'm trying all
right they just as well we just lose our
virginities or something
yeah that's a weird okay we're time go
potty watching overtime a bit so I'm
going bad let's go to username this is
going to be a good one because I need to
see all of their usernames I'm actually
know like a foot all right this is weird
we're just like ton of random stuff and
it's just legal I don't feel like we're
getting anywhere especially here what
makes a man what makes a man describe
your best friend let me ask you what
makes a man
cannot see anything what just happened
it makes a man what makes a man I think
anything makes a man like I don't think
anything makes a man just being a man is
enough dang this is so difficult
these are big questions that requires
first I don't like Ted bro you're gonna
have to choose another person to vote
for sweet so odd that's kind of sucks we
had some very bad issues with connection
although the app seemed to have
depression well I'm still not very
trusting of Tristan so I'm gonna vote
for him again
I think I'm out i I really I really
think I'm out this round I don't think
Ted did enough to get other people
against him all right
mmm I went with Ted
I'm gonna go Christopher
I had it to someone I don't know I don't
feel like I'm catching up okay I think
I'm voting Chandler he said it the Alpha
energy is drowning me at one point I
also knew a girl named Chandler growing
up shout-out Chandler
hope you doing well Chandler connection
issues on the first round I get booted
out the second round I'm looking forward
to seeing who the girl actually turns
out to be I still got my money heavily
on Tristan good luck to the other dudes
I guess when was the last time you cried
[Music]
I've asked how many people we're gonna
keep in when we call it how many people
do you want by the time we call it I
don't remember the last time I cried I
don't think most guys are comfortable
crying so I think that's a pretty good
answer most guys don't know what the
last time you cried was because they I
cried the proposal come out monster
you know I got real sick a while back in
that miss me
damn okay last time I cried I don't like
touch that I cried at the proposal
because I'm not a monster
I said yes that I understand that makes
it real I said my mom got real take a
while back and that messed me up
she had a traumatic brain injury but
we're good now we're fine now but it was
great time that was probably last time I
really really cried what's something
that makes you your time a crime trying
to sadness I don't feel like I just feel
like I just deal with the repercussions
yeah miss skinny gotta constantly though
her abilities too bro yes you can now
we're talking about vulnerabilities and
stuff and my big one is that my biceps
are what you put in between graham
crackers and people always body shaming
yeah we get body shame for being skinny
but I don't think it's as bad as women I
think women get it a lot worse at three
weeks you're getting close to three
minutes
I think it's so true and when it comes
to late guys appearances you see so many
people attacking them and not defending
them itself somebody comes to like body
image with the women it's like as soon
as you say anything negative you get
attacked but when it's such a guy it's
like everyone's making the joke
everyone's like poking fun it's the
exact same things like this double
standard everyone expects us to look a
certain way and somehow okay to talk
about how we should look but it's
somehow so else you're building be like
eating disorders are a thing then
happened to estimate said I'm so skinny
people keep on telling you starve
yourself even I'll work out a unit time
how do I feel that you sort of a real
thing
I mean happen to it's a real thing and
it is stuff so now we're talking about
weight and I quoted my weight which is
145 have a fast metabolism no matter
what AEM 145 and that's the truth I mean
I'm starting to work out now but I still
feel like I'm really I started alright
you've gotten to a go go straight to my
20 that's a real thing do you guys feel
awkward with the pressure of being the
one to make the first move every tip it
every time I'm terrible at making the
first move
and it's like every girl does that so
every time the guy has to wait for the
girls kick ass get it's a lot but heads
mm-hmm I don't like to I've had a girl
literally just sleep in my bed because I
couldn't make the first move
that's pretty specific I'm starting to
suspect running damn it I just love this
Wow send me your vote privately for who
you want to eliminate next
oddly emotional hearing all of them talk
about like vulnerability and their
struggles it's just like heartbreaking I
think I'm gonna have to go a salade not
to say they like I think he is less of a
man it's only because I felt like he
didn't contribute as much to the
conversation or I'm not that I could see
because I was like reading and they
responding and then I wasn't reading the
next messages I don't know what to think
I'm going with Ted suggesting her
therapy and just being nice to everybody
and building everybody up you know it's
a cool thing that guys do when they're
with other guys that trust each other I
just I'm suspicious it's difficult to
choose who's really going to better
really thinks that way Dan I wish all
these guys the best
I wish all these people the best I'm
still going Christopher so I think all
of us got really vulnerable so it's
really hard for like especially me to
focus and be like okay I think so odd is
probably my guy he asked questions that
surprised me but like I haven't thought
about Brian
maybe so on me that's a guy I'm in I'm
an emotional person I feel a lot of
things and I'm not scared to show them
off I showed my vulnerabilities and I
paid the price for it I guess but that's
just who I am
I'm true to myself and that's the realty
this is my
[Music]
if you don't think that the mole is in
the game and you want to end the game
give me a thumbs up there will be lights
that appear behind me if the lights are
green the mole is gone and you win if
the lights are red the mole is still in
and the mole wins I'm sitting here
reading they're talking about having
legitimately feel betrayed also I feel
even more guilty because I have my
bitmoji like avatar staring at me
everybody turn on your cameras and 3 2 2
1 1 go
[Music]
what was your game plan I'm sure there's
a guy out there that's literally just
like me but a guy and he's a guy right
so why do I have to pretend I don't know
I was just like I'll just be myself and
play it real but the pant sizes you guys
almost got me there I said that was a
great question I didn't suspect to Brie
at all or Brian there's no way to tell
who is a man or a woman based on the
chat good job Rhea never thought Brian
this is why I have trust issues now and
that was the hard part for me I
literally oh my god my stuff so bad when
it comes to what defines a man I don't
know because the lines are getting
blurrier and blurrier it was kind of
refreshing to have this open dialogue
and to have open dialogue of like being
a woman listen
- a man's problem without him thinking
that I wouldn't understand you know
they're talking to me like I am one of
them and it just creates it this whole
new way of understanding each other
[Music]